Tucker Carlson is in Moscow that's kind
of weird there was some chatter about
this I didn't mention it on the show
yesterday because it was still a little
bit unclear Tucker has now confirmed it
he flew to Moscow to interview Vladimir
Putin we're in Moscow tonight we're here
to interview the president of Russia
Vladimir Putin we'll be doing that soon
almost 3 years ago the Biden
Administration illegally spied on our
text messages and then leak the contents
to their servants in the news media they
did this in order to stop a Putin
interview that we were planning
last month we're pretty certain they did
exactly the same thing once again but
this time we came to Moscow
anyway we are not here because we love
Vladimir Putin we are here because we
love the United States and we want it to
remain prosperous and
free I can't wait to watch it I Tucker
is already being preemptively criticized
for the interview already there are
political cartoons about how he's a
Putin puppet and a Putin stooge and and
whatever but I don't really really see
why we would preemptively attack him for
for even conducting the
interview plenty of American journalists
have interviewed Vladimir Putin he's not
the first one to do it Megan Kelly
interviewed Vladimir Putin Barbara
Walters interviewed Vladimir Putin I
plenty of people have done it over the
years now in the past the United States
was trying to have some sort of repr
rosmont with Putin there were they were
trying to encourage Putin to liberalize
they were
and guess now we're not doing that I
guess now we're saying Putin is the
worst guy ever and they're calling him
Hitler 2.0 and what so I understand why
the liberal establishment doesn't want
any more interviews with Vladimir Putin
but that's not good enough for me the
liberal establishment's wrong about a
ton of
stuff so I just I'm not I'm not going
into the interview thinking Tucker did a
great job or just as he says I love
Vladimir Putin or I don't know I don't
know if the interview is going to be
good or bad I don't have any particular
sympathy for Vladimir
Putin but I do know that the the liberal
establishment lies to me all the
time so I'll keep an open mind I'll be
listening isn't aren't the Liberals the
ones who always tell us knowledge is
power man keep an open mind collect all
the information we can't suppressing and
but then the the moment you've got a
major world leader who's been a world
leader for 20 plus years now we can't
listen to him it seems kind of crazy to
me along with the federal government
spying on a journalist's text messages
and the current leader of the
opposition's text messages Donald Trump
and then trying to throw him in prison I
don't know I I'm sure Putin has done all
sorts of terrible things just like chian
Ping has done all sorts of terrible
things but as our government becomes
increasingly tyrannical and
irrational I'm certainly interested in
hearing from
non-official non- Liberal establishment
approved sources right now go to
hall.com lent the 40 days leading up to
Easter starts on Ash Wednesday day which
is the day after Marty gr Fat Tuesday
and this year as Wednesday is also on St
Valentine's Day February 14th this is a
time of intense prayer fasting and
giving Hallow's annual pray 40 challenge
is one of their most popular last year
over a million people joined this year's
pray 40 challenge focuses on surrender
and includes meditations on the powerful
book he leadth me the story about a
priest who became a prisoner and slave
in the Soviet Union during the Cold War
his story is one of Ultimate Surrender
and we are called to offer up our own
worries anxieties problems and lives to
God there will also be lent music lent
specific Bible stories and other lent in
prayers such as The Seven Last Words of
Christ with Jim cisel hallo is truly
transformative and will help you connect
with your faith on a deeper level so
what are you waiting for download the
hall app today at hall.com
kwes for an exclusive three-month free
trial of all 6,000 plus prayers and
meditations that is
hello.com I had this question you got
you got our political leaders just
forcing stuff that nobody really wants
down our throats weakening our country
throwing open our borders and and
Americans a lot of them are going along
with it how did we become so weak how
did we become so
servile and I think ice spice actually
demonstrates part of the way that
happened she has a new song out it's
called you you ain't the
parentheses f a
t Miss spice take it
away what not even f i be
going I'm
breakings Qui but I'm
[Music]
quicker keep going that's all we okay
that's all we need actually this reminds
me of a line from Playdoh as the musings
of ice spice often
do from I
think I I forget exactly which book of
Plato's Republic he writes quote musical
training is a more potent instrument
than any other because Rhythm and
Harmony find their way into the inward
places of the Soul on which they
mightily fasten imparting Grace and
making the soul of him who is rightly
educated graceful or of him who is
ill-educated
ungraceful which do you think this does
Alan Bloom great uh humanist and a great
conservative writer of the 20th century
he he in his book closing of the
American mind had a chapter on how rock
music is really bad for you because it
it arouses the base passions and rock
music is like brumms compared to ice
spice this is music for Animals this the
the music itself is for Animals
just just jiggling around smacking
yourself as ice spice is doing but the
lyrics also are for animals or the
animals you think you're the
but you're not even the
Ft you you think you're rich but I'm
richer you think you're quick but I'm
quicker and it goes on and it's so
disgusting and crass and vulgar I can't
get it out of my head it's so overthe
toop in its vulgarity that I find it
funny and I actually have texted it to a
few people because I can't get over it
but it's it's very depressing because
this is popular music this isn't just
some little track that came out from
some unheard of musician on the internet
somewhere as a joke this was debuted at
some big Spotify event this is a woman
who's done collaborations with Taylor
Swift other prominent musicians I I'm
not as familiar with the ice spice
U but she's a very popular musician and
this is the kind of slop cultural slop
that goes out out there for I'm sorry to
say we the increasingly unwashed
masses this is it and and when this is
bouncing around your head well it's not
really bouncing around your head it's
bouncing around your loins it's bouncing
around your your lower passions but what
what Plato says is true this surpasses
and subverts your reason so you're not
reasoning about this when you sit and
listen to some classical music or
Gregorian chant or something it's much
more intellectual it's much more
rational because you're you're not
immediately aroused and bumping and
grinding and bouncing and twerking and
doing all the stuff that ice spice is
doing but this kind of music make makes
you behave less like a rational soul and
more just like an animal you know just
kind of bouncing around and thinking
about bodily functions and fluids and
movements and uh if if we treat
ourselves and educate ourselves to be
like animals if this is the kind of
stuff that forms our soul then we're
going to be ruled like animals then
we're going to be ruled like a bunch of
pigs and cows and sheep which is
increasingly how our political order
works man what a great clip that was now
hey hold up hold up man ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles Show
podcast we'll see you next time